وفي جدل دراما اليوم جوله سريعه لابرز ما
تشهده دراما رمضانيه مع الناقد طارق
الشناوي من القاهره ينضم الينا الناقد
الفني طارق الشناوي اهلا بك سيد طارق معنا
دائما في مساء العربيه برمضان نورنا اهلا
بك اهلا بكم تشرفني
طيب نبدا حديثنا سيد طارق بن جدل حول
المسلسل تاريخي رساله الامام والذي طالته
انتقادات حاده واتهامات بيعضوا معلومات
خاطئه وغير صحيحه عن حياه الامام الشافعي
ما رايك بهذا الجذر
[موسيقى]
الازهر الشريف وهو طبعا جهه في العالم كله
لها كل تقدير واحترام رجعت النصوص
الحلقات واقرت بها وهنلاقي حتى على في
التتريات اسماء عديده جدا
مختلفه حتى في توجهتها ده بيؤكد على ان
الوقائع يعني تم مراجعتها مؤكد ان في في
اي تاريخ في مناطق بيبقى فيها اكتر من
روايه الكاتب الدرامي من حقه ان يختار
الروايه التي تتصق مع الخط الفكري اللي
عايز يعبر عنه وفي مساحات اساسا لم يذكرها
التاريخ يعني ممكن مثلا لقاء الامام
الشافعي براهب كنيسه ممكن ما يبقاش ده
موجود في يعني ما فيش فيه وثيقه لكن لكن
طالما الشخصيه نفسها لا تمنع انك انت انه
يلتقي مع راهب في الكنيسه وانه ياخذ منه
دواء حتى لو كان هو يعني عنده درايه بالطب
انا مش شايف فيها اي حاجه لانو ازاي ان هو
ياخد من راهب كنيسه
تركيب الدواء وهو كان عالم بالادويه اظن
ده ما هواش سبب انه يخليه ما يروحش لراهب
كنيسه والمعنى كمان العميق واضح اللي عايز
يقوله امام الشافعي التسامح مع الاديان
يعني ودي اظن رساله احنا محتاجينها في
عالمنا الاسلامي
يا استاذ طارق يبقى الجدل مستمرا رغم
كثافه وزحمت كل الاعمال الدراميه قبل ان
اذهب الى الجدل الثاني حول العمل الثاني
خلينا نتابع مع بعض كليب ونتمنى نعود اليك
يعني زي ما شفنا هذا مشهد لمحمد سعد فينو
غضب كواليس تصوير مسلسل الجديد وانتشر هذا
الفيديو وهو يطلق بعد عبارات سباب وايضا
كانه طاقم العمل بالتقصير بمسلسل اكسيلونس
شو اللي صار يا استاذ طارق يعني لماذا
شباك بهذا الحجم
انا انا حزين على فنان كبير وموهبه كبيره
جدا ياما اتكلمت عن مواهبته اللي هو محمد
سعد لكن في السنوات العشر الاخيره لم يكن
في الاثنى عشر الاخيره لم يستطع محمد سعد
الحفاظ على المكاسب الحقها على مستوى
الجمهور
واعماله الاخيره فعلا
سواء كانت في التليفزيون او في السينما
اثبتت ان الجمهور بدا يعني سحب عنه
المشكله مش في موهبه محمد سعد المشكله انه
محمد سعد فقد روح المغامره بياخد من الدرج
او بالخزين ويعيد تقديمه مره يسخنه يعني
بيسموها مثلا في مصر يقول لك يامر رغيف
العيش يامره يعني يسخنه كده فهو يجي يامر
البضاعه الدراميه القديمه او الشخصيه
القديمه ويقدمها هنا الفنان بيفقد روح
المغامره بيفقد في نفس اللحظه روح الابداع
ثوره محمد سعد
اللي سببها الاخفاق الرقمي اللي عمله
المسلسل انه مشاهدته ضئيله متابعته ضئيله
لكن هو لو فكر شويه هيكتشف ان في مشاكل في
الكتابه هو مسؤول عنها ايضا لانها وافق
على النص في مشاكل في الاخراج في مشاكل
عند محمد سعد في اختياره للشخصيه نفسها
لانه سبق ان هو قدمها يعني في كركر سبق
تقديم الشخصيه دي فهو مش قادر يهرب بره
مضيء لا محمد سعد موهبه لكن عليه ان يتحرر
من الماضي وانا حزين حزين جدا انه يعني
بالمقطع اللي احنا سمعناه وتقريبا العالم
العربي كله سمعوا في تجاوزات في تجاوزات
حتى اضطر فريق العمل او المخرج انه يقول
لا ما كانش موجهه لنا يعني بيقولوا يا
استاذ طارق غلطه الشاطر بالف غلطه الشاطر
بالف على كل حال شاطر عمال يغلط بقاله
يغلط بقاله مرات دلوقتي يعني احنا كمان
بنتمنى دايما ان الامور تصير على خير
خلينا اذا رحنا لتوجه مسلسل سفر برلك
للمخرج السوري ليث حجه عم يحقق نجاح لافت
يعني كما اعتدنا وشاهدنا اليوم عندما عادت
دراما المصريه واذا ما تحدثنا عن مسلسل
تاريخي للامام الشافعي استعانت ايضا
بالمخرج هل هذا يا استاذ طارق يؤكد
المقوله كانت تتردد في مطلع الالفيه انه
مصر مثلا تتفوق في الاجتماعي وسوريا لا
ينافسها احد في الدراما التاريخيه هل يوجد
تخصص مثلا في دراما يرتبط ببلد محدد انصح
التعبير
بصي الموضوع ده اتقال من اكتر من عشره سنه
انا متذكر وحتى وقالوا انه السجاده
التاريخي سحبتها سوريا من مصر فاكره انا
بسام كوسه وده فنان سوري معروف
وكبير قال لي هو فين السجاده قال لي فين
السجاده يعني عايز اقول انه يعني تعودنا
على مثل هذه الاقوي لكن لا شك ان الدراما
التاريخيه السوريه
من من اجمل واعمق واحلى الاعمال الدراميه
التاريخيه اللي انا شفتها وليس حقه كان
استعانه به انا بحسبها استعانه تحسب تحسب
للقائمين على الانتاج او للشركه المتحده
لانها راحت الى مخرج سوري وماشي الجنسيه
لكن هذا المخرج يعني هيقدم لها عمل فني
عظيم ففعلا واثبت اثبت قدرته فالراجل له
مسلسل
معروضين بكل قوه على اكتر من المنصهرين
نجاحها طاغي ده دليل على قوته ولكن هل
يعني مش مش هيتقدم مثلا عمل تاريخي مصري
حتى طبعا العمل الفني بينسب للانتاج مش
الاخراج بس هفترض جدلا هل مش ممكن مخرج
مصري يملك ادواته اكيد ممكن يكون فيه لكن
ليس حجه
موجود ومحافظ على ابداعه وانه لازم مصر
تعمل كده طالما في مخرج موهوب
مرحب واهلا به والليث احد اهم المواهب
العربيه كلها وانت يا استاذ طارق استاذ في
كل حاجه يعني وانت منورنا دائما في مسائل
عربيه وان شاء الله كمان بنشوفك في كل يوم
لانه للحديث تتمه ومش راح تخلص وما رح
يخلص الجدل في الشهر
ناقد الفني طارق الشناوي شكرا لك